tra tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vigente ed oggi siamo
tornati sul turbo di smau ragazzi se va
bene oggi in teoria vorrei riuscire a
finire i livelli perché me ne mancavano
pochissimi che non aveva ancora fatto
come ragazzino pronto un casino di
livelli l'ultima volta volevo venire se
ce n'erano alcuni che non aveva ancora
fatto di pochi poi le immerge a caso se
ti prendo questo l'avevo fatto invece
purtroppo io voglio parlare vedere ecco
ci sia eccolo qui ragazzi voglio vederlo
in prima persona perché l'ultima volta
l'ho fatto malissimo
ok bene spiegarsi che fruttare della
madonna
allora ragazzi no io non vi prometto
niente però o days
ho dei seri dubbi che possa concludere
qualcosa in questo modo però non importa
io ci provo lo stesso perché ho fiducia
in lui è andata meglio di quanto
pensassi levate dai [ __ ] figli di
zaza prova affatto tranquilli sono un
pompiere sono qui per mettere un po
d'ordine
non preoccupatevi ci penso altri affari
tranquilli di ragazzi e non mi faccio
neanche più domande cioè non so perché
lo sto facendo proposto facendo e basta
buono lo era kat von d appreso non mi ha
preso riga non mi ha preso un nonno
anche emma sei stronzo allora che ho io
se faccio un provino per matrix
giuro che mi prendi come casa ha fatto
non prendermi due ragazzi faccio un
ultimo perché volevo provare a rendere
anche qui sopra perché giustamente le
montagne russe non sono niente in
confronto a quanto sono finte ovviamente
nell'art a classi a fantastico fantasy
un passaggio
grazie un altro passo grazie un altro
post raccolta ragazzi cambiamo livello
grandi mz che cazzo è sta roba
cos'è ma ragazzo sono figo sono mine io
non ho idea di che cazzo siano quei
cosima ma io è il mio bel faccione sulla
macchina andremo a scoprirlo andare
eccolo lì ecco ragazzi siete pronti
io penso siano mine ma non ne sono
sicuro non devi girare devi andare devi
andare in mezzo ma sei stupido cosa io
seriamente porno ma perché gira regalo
perchè sai perché stai girando demente
fermo poi sfondato deve andare ma
ovunque tranne dove deve andare cazzo
devi andare lì devi andare lì e ci siamo
ragazze possiamo fare
io no io ho paura sinceramente me la
possiamo fare via poiché utilizza mi sa
che sono mine tu sai che sono qualcosa
mi dice che sono mine però non ne sono
completamente sicuro
ok ok ok perfetto io un tempo avevo un
camion sua volta mi butto la visuale su
di me perché sennò non capisco cosa sta
succedendo ok piano ho detto piano di
cosa fai camion
[Musica]
sì ragazzi si può andare in skate un
gradino devi superare un gradino come
cazzo è possibile un gradino devi fare
dio santo ragazzi ce la faccio io con lo
skate con un gradino che non ci vado
nemmeno sullo skate dio mio
andiamo coi motori con questo ti piace
piace motorino bravo al motorino lo
skate non gli fanno gli fa cagare lo si
fa cazzo di spazio che c'è ma proprio
sul palo devi firma [ __ ] ragazzi
una cosa che mi avete chiesto di provare
che non ho fatto e devo assolutamente
fare devo assolutamente fare questo in
questa posizione remo farlo ho scritto
favi fai così vince chi è trovata grazie
a quella una volta era mia moto una
volta perché accusati non se voglio
provare questa ecco perfetto così non
l'avevo provata nel nostro servizio non
so che cos'è lillo che sia tratto dalla
mia bella faccia sexy ragazzi non so
perchè mi sta guardando in questo modo
ma la mia faccia mentre sto per morire è
la cosa che non vorrei guardare però mi
dispiace perdere come cazzo fatto
salvarmi e diavolo ho fatto salvarmi
regalo sexy
sa cazzo sta succedendo oddio oddio no
no no ecco perfetto ho buttato giù il
muro ma non era quello che tu non puoi
passi certo ragazzi mi è rimasto un
braccio solo e neanche il resto del
corpo ma vabbè io ragazzo seriamente
paura di che cazzo social paura mica
barista giorno ma che cazzo è successo
ecco prospetta ecco il pro skater ce la
faremo
perché tu valgono di merda mi stabili
sul culo e doveva colpire che il culo
sec stata data trata salve salve da
tanto datata 3 the fact that there s
se ci sia un ragazzo veltroni in pista
non andò mai in casa di fronte
90 gioco solo eccolo qui è che metta il
po vigente mette fuori jack e pisa fa
dire a tutti sotto terra perché chi
cazzo mi amor de travail spinta la mia
testa ragazzi non regga miss qualità
avete messo la mia testa a lou reed i
ladri di merda dove basta
scusaci falli ragazzi voglio provare
frodi anche l'ultimo nell'ultimo
episodio non la non c'ero riuscito per
niente a farla perché è impossibile io
provo ad andare così reagan non vi
prometto niente perché non uno a caso di
macchina c'era ma che avrà piccoli dalle
palle lurida ma mi ha rotto le palle
finché non mi sono fermato ma dio mio ok
se si sia una sega riparo da ben pochi
avanti si sono andato a me ma ragazzi
perché avviene c'è gente che prende il
pullman e c'è gente che prende pullman
lo prende non potevi andare a far la
spesa a comprare la torta stamattina
invece di rompere le palle ameri e poi
si in groppa norma ma sabato come che in
groppa qualsiasi cosa vede ho perso le
speranze richiamo unep non è possibile
non è possibile
this is minchia la macchina sì sì sì no
no no no no no no no no no no ma quanto
mi mancava niente
no ho sentite vanno [ __ ] io cdp non
ne può succedere dai min
ormai non ci riuscirò mai più già capito
tutti a [ __ ] tutto sorella ragazzi
mimì fatevi fare quella del parco e vi
prego una volta sola quella del
parcheggio perché bellissima eccola
perfetto ragazzi se riesco in questa
giro a nudo giuro fi
bye bye bye
se finora non ci sono riuscito a meno
male perché dovevo girare nudo per casa
e sarebbe stato un problema che sta roba
rega che non ho ancora fatto ma giuro
non ho ancora fatto una cosa che non
macchine che vanno dal lato opposto no
no come lo scriva targa no no no no
macché caccia stavo facendo anche non è
possibile ragazzi ci vado in skate
perché ho paura
sinceramente ho paura di finire sotto
una macchina cosa molto probabile
porca [ __ ] che è forzata eccoci rigas
perfetto dovremmo riuscirci così credo
perché ciò che il bilanciamento
si no maledizione non poteva passarci
sotto nel caso di autobus
oddio ragazzo non sono ancora sullo
skate a metà loro ci sono casa successo
ragazzi
oddio che abominio è questo io non so
ragazzi siamo riusciti ad apprezzare la
la la sec saggine di questa posizione
bellissima e io io veramente vinto amido
alla danza classica da adesso in avanti
nani ok
sì sì in piedi in piedi soldato in piedi
adesso vai avanti come se non ci portavo
se sì ce l'ho fatto a cazzo mangi
la chiosa piacere che posso concludere
qui comunque volevo dirvi lega che sto
gioco a pieno pieno zeppo di livelli
bonus che non ha ancora fatto la prima
di farli ragazzi volevo finire quelli
normali di livelli così che avete già
visto e dal prossimo episodio che farà
voglio iniziare a fare i livelli quelli
veramente tosti un carica lo vedrete nel
prossimo episodio direi che possono
concludere qui nonostante ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
ogni minuto la descrizione allora se la
green city scrivetele ci vediamo al
prossimo mito bella ragazzi